hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll what you're hearing right now is
a last-minute blurb i am appending to
the beginning of the podcast to make an
announcement that some of you may have
seen on either twitter or my blog the
other day namely that i'm moving from
caltech to johns hopkins in baltimore
maryland my new title will be homewood
professor of natural philosophy how cool
is that i gotta say uh the homewood
professorships are special kind of
positions that in principle float freely
above specific departmental lines but
for practical purposes this is a joint
appointment between the physics
department and the philosophy department
i will have offices in both departments
i'll take students in both departments
teach courses the whole bit so it's
extremely exciting for me because rather
than
doing philosophy type things or even
doing public facing outreachy type
things or doing a podcast and kind of
having that be in addition to my job all
that stuff is now part of my job i am a
philosopher as well as a physicist card
carrying right now and all of the
podcasts writing books giving talks kind
of stuff they want me to do that
this is the first time in my academic
life when this is actually encouraged
rather than tolerated so very very
exciting for me we're moving over the
summer nothing bad to say about caltech
it's been a great place but this
particular position with a lot of people
who i already know
is just exactly right for me there's
several people who we've had
here on the podcast on mindscape already
at johns hopkins henry farrell uh the
political scientist adam reese of course
the astronomer emily real the
mathematician so it's a very very
exciting time you can read more if you
go to the blog and i explain what it's
all about the other thing i wanted to
very quickly note is that this podcast
was recorded about existential threats
to humanity and the political response
to them uh over a month ago before we
were in the current crisis that actually
makes us think about existential risks
and the political response to them so
it was not recognition it's just that
some topics never go away okay now
return to our regularly scheduled
podcast you know when i think about
guests for the podcast i have rules i
have hidden rules in my brain about what
kind of person i want for the podcast
and what kind i don't i don't always
make these explicit because i retain the
rights to change the rules there are my
own rules i made them up right one of
the rules is no politicians
no working politicians or people who are
currently running for office and it's
not that i have anything against
politics i'm in fact i'm extremely in
favor of politics done right of course
politics can be done wrong and it can be
very tiresome
and people's iqs can go down when they
start talking about politics but i'm a
huge believer that politics is important
that we need to
invest both our
intellectual and organizational energies
in making politics work and getting the
right people into the right places and
thinking carefully about what that means
who the right people are what the right
places are
but i also recognize there's a
difference between the activity of
politics and the activity of
understanding the world you know there's
a activism intellectual divide both are
important but for mindscape i'm much
more interested in the intellectual side
of things even if we have you know
musicians or whatever on the podcast
it's about the craft it's about how you
think about these things that it's not
about people's personal histories and
gossip it's also not about
individual policy proposals that people
are trying to get through or individual
candidates who are trying to be elected
into office so rough rule no politicians
on the podcast and i'm violating that
rule today and again it's my rule i made
it up so i'm allowed to violate it but
today's guest is andrew lee who is a
member of parliament in australia and
i'll explain why i violated the rules
for one thing andrew comes from a kind
of academic-y background he has a phd in
public policy he was a professor of
economics at australian national
university
and he has a new book out uh just a few
months ago
and the new book is called what's the
worst that could happen existential risk
and extreme politics it's a book about
existential risks which we've talked
about before in the podcast with people
like martin reese and nick postrom
but in the down-to-earth political
context what do we really do about these
existential risks the book is published
by mit
press you know most politicians books
are not published by mit press so given
the topic of the book and andrew's
background and the fact is a serious
intellectual book i thought it would
make a good choice for the podcast and
that's what we're talking about we're
talking about existential risks so we go
through the usual list of options right
there's climate change bioterrorism
asteroid hitting the earth and we try to
think about both what these risks are
and also what we should do about them at
a fairly down-to-earth level what can
governments do what can people do etc
and for better for worse you know we end
up or at least in my mind the
interesting part of the conversation was
really not any policy proposal so much
as a perspective proposal that you know
people
need to individually think about the
world and where the world is going in a
slightly different way if we are to take
these kinds of existential risks
seriously i think it's a pretty easy
case to make that we should take them
seriously we can argue about the margins
on about the details about exactly how
much resource or time or effort we
should put into
mitigating existential risks but we
should be able to agree
that something that has a non-trivial
chance of ending human life
or even causing enormous disastrous
consequences for most human beings
that's something we should worry about
even if it's going to happen after our
individual lifetimes even if it's going
to happen 100 or 200 years down in the
future so that's what we do we take
these seriously andrew explains how you
know he didn't come into office in
parliament being the existential risk
guy you know he has been thinking about
it since arriving and he cares now about
things like super intelligent ai in a
way that he didn't before so
as with anyone you can agree or disagree
about his particular diagnoses but it's
food for thought it's making us think
about these big things that are
look i'll be honest some of them are
kind of scary some of them are very real
like one of andrew's points is this is
not a one in hundred thousand chance
this is a much bigger chance than we
might hope that there really is going to
be something disastrous that happens in
the foreseeable future so let's think
about it that's the first step to
preventing it that's where we are for
this podcast so let's go
[Music]
andrew lee welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks sean great to be with you
we're talking about existential risks so
that's something a phrase i'm sure
people have heard before why don't just
so we're grounded just so we're starting
on the same page why don't you just give
us a list of some of your favorite
existential risks what are your top
three to sort of worry about when you're
worried about these things
well sean existential risks i think of
as things which would either end
humanity or
fundamentally alter the the trajectory
of the human project
i guess those are most concerned about
uh would be nuclear war
bioterrorism and artificial intelligence
gone awry
but you can think of other possibilities
uh climate unchecked climate change even
an asteroid hitting the earth which is
uh
featured in the the new netflix film
don't look up um so there's a plethora
of ways things could go wrong none of
them probable but the possibilities are
big enough that i think it's worth us
investing a bit more time and energy and
making sure they don't happen
i guess one question is there is a
distinction between existential risk in
the sense of truly ending
all of humanity or even all of life on
earth versus
causing a incredible disruption that
would be terrible without actually
making us dis
extinct i mean i don't really think of
climate change as something that could
literally end humanity on earth although
it could cause tremendous disruption in
poverty and hardship and so forth do you
think that's an important distinction to
make
absolutely because the distinction is
one between
future generations not existing
and future generations having a
diminished quality of life for the human
project taking a couple of centuries to
get back on track and i think climate
change is a great example there sean
because it is the one where i was most
hesitant initially to include it in a
list of catastrophic risks and
eventually was the work of the harvard
scholar marty weinstein who passed away
a number of years ago
that persuaded me it was worth including
and he makes the case that the odds of a
six degree climate rise might be one in
ten the odds of a 10 degree celsius
climate rise might be one in a hundred
and if you're talking about a 10 degree
rise you really are talking about
something which takes us into the realms
of catastrophe could you actually i know
this is not the primary uh
topic here but can you explain exactly
how catastrophic it would be i mean
presumably all the ice sheets melt and
the water level rises but also there's
other things going on you must have
thought about this
absolutely you see a big rise in
violence which is strongly correlated
with uh with heat you see huge loss of
crops and potential global famines
taking place naturally
range of coastal cities are immediately
wiped out by the sea level rise but the
degree of catastrophic weather events
would be utterly unprecedented uh you
did there's a number of scientists who
point to venus which uh
millions of years back had an atmosphere
not that different from the earth's
but due to climate change is now
completely uninhabitable it's the
hottest planet in the solar system 460
degrees celsius on this on the surface
and as a result of climate change uh
venus became utterly uninhabitable so
it's that possibility of the the second
venus scenario if you like that that
caused me to put climate change in the
catastrophic risk basket well let's see
i there's a big difference between 10
degrees and a few hundred degrees uh i
i'm just i wasn't actually planning on
delving into the details here but are
there atmospheric science mechanisms
that would let us go
totally haywire and become sort of a
almost venus-like planet
well i mean so if you go to the
particular venus example sean um
there's
they had a runaway greenhouse effect
evaporating water led to a steam blanket
which warmed the planet even further
then the water vapor broke into hydrogen
oxygen and the hydrogens literally swept
away by solar winds
the process took place three and a half
billion years ago
and took about 10 million years to get
rid of the water on venus okay
again we're talking about very low
probabilities but given how catastrophic
it is uh it seems to strengthen the case
for climate for action on sensible
climate policies uh that avert
temperature rises
no okay i think i think that's very good
very helpful so that's like millions of
years kind of thing and uh and this is
the one place you are allowed to talk
about you know a tiny percentage but
over millions of years and we'll
speculate about the future in that way
and no we won't hold you accounting
accountable for it we're not going to
say that you predicted we'll become
venus don't worry uh
but but the worry about you know 10
degree climate uh temperature increase
over 100 years um
i guess there's a feeling that some
people might have that climate change is
somebody else's problem even if it's a
problem you know if someone is already
you know relatively well off if they
don't live near the coast
they probably have a feeling that
they'll get through it okay
and i think that's what you're you're
pointing at is not going to be as easy
as maybe people think
yes that's right and uh climate change
is the classic collective action problem
one in which uh it is very easy to take
the global litter bug approach you know
if i just throw my trash on the sidewalk
then really that's not gonna make a big
difference to how messy the streets are
but if everyone does it it really does
make a big difference
so just as we should pick up our trash
we should also
have an interest in common pool
solutions
and you know you're seeing
more of that of that movement with the
paris climate talks and glasgow talks uh
but again we're uh a long way off where
we need to be right so let me ask you
let's let's with that on board uh let's
back up a little bit let me ask you has
your way of thinking about issues like
this changed since you've become a
working politician i mean you started
out as an academic
now you can actually have a vote in some
ways that professors don't uh did you
learn more did you realize it's more
important than you thought or is it more
or less what you expected
yeah it's a great question because you
know i went into politics in 2010 i was
not largely concerned with catastrophic
risk
climate change was on my radar but
certainly unchecked artificial
intelligence wasn't
and it was thinking in a probabilistic
sense and uh envisaging what it could be
to end the human project that really
brought catastrophic risks to uh to my
attention um
ord's estimate is that there is a one in
six
chance that the human project ends in
the next century
and if that's true and that continues to
be true over the next millennium then
you can think of it as playing repeated
rounds of russian roulette for a
millennium uh one in six chance that you
did in a in a century but a five in six
chance you did in the millennium uh so
that then made me feel that this was
an issue which was getting much too
little attention
and particularly as a politician i guess
the lens i bring to the discussion
around catastrophic risk
is thinking about how populism makes the
problem worse
by causing a focus on the short term
rather than the long term firing up the
temperature destroying institutions and
undermining international cooperation
so that's my particular lens on
catastrophic risk
when you first became a politician when
you started talking to your uh
colleagues i guess it's a parliament
parliamentary system in australia right
yes
then did they just roll their eyes or do
people in that position get it you know
is there a common feeling that
with different degrees of urgency
perhaps but that we should worry about
this kind of thing
i mean the risks of uh sort of ebbed and
flowed uh when i was a kid in the 1980s
i remember having a conversation with
one of my schoolmates we must have been
grade four or something we both agreed
that there was no chance that we would
uh finish high school because the world
would be destroyed by nuclear
catastrophe
uh and uh that was that was incredibly
salient at that time in recent years i
think people have taken on the notion
that pandemics can be pretty serious
and climate change has also come to the
fore
but unchecked artificial intelligence
which on my estimate is
the most worrying catastrophic risk
is still regarded by many as being in
the realm of science fiction
so the individual risks have been taken
on sporadically by the political
establishment uh but less so the notion
of catastrophic risk as a whole
that i think that makes sense that's
what i would have guessed that's
interesting to hear and i mean do you
feel that when you talk to them about it
they're willing to listen or is it i can
imagine that as a working politician
they're like how does this get me votes
back home this is not something where
people's attention is really focused
yeah although it's interesting right so
so you take that uh that moment in 1998
when the bruce willis film armageddon
and the steven spielberg movie deep
impact come out
immediately there is a response
nasa sets up its planetary defense
coordination office uh you have
you know ted cruz famously asking and
hearing what steps do we have to be
taking so we don't have to rely on
sending bruce willis to space to save
humanity
and and big increases in spending on
planetary defence and tracking
near-earth objects in some sense
politics has uh has tackled that one uh
it's our response to asteroids isn't
perfect uh but we've
we've responded pretty uh in a in a
pretty pretty bipartisan way in most
countries around the world and yet
climate change is is the opposite uh of
here people are deeply deeply divided uh
and there hasn't been the same sort of
unified response at least in the united
states and australia uh that we've seen
to do asteroid risk
i mean you're really saying something
provocative by giving credit to two
movies to hollywood blockbusters uh for
political action on asteroids i mean is
that a lesson right there you know a
lesson for people who do care about
things that maybe we should be trying
harder to leverage popular culture to
really get people work up about this
well yeah i think that's probably the
exception rather than the rule sean
because there have been so many movies
about catastrophe like it's one of
hollywood's favorite films
so you think about the pandemic movies
outbreak carriers contagion the
bioterrorism movies 12 monkeys v for
vendetta
the nuclear war movies doctor
strangelove on the beach
artificial intelligence movies avengers
age of ultron terminator and even the
climate change movies so waterworld mad
max fury road blade runner 2049
so we've hollywood has uh uh got us to
the edge of our seats but that hasn't
always gotten people off the couch to
deal with uh a catastrophic risk uh and
you need to to bring it together and i
think also to paint a picture sean which
says um it is not that hard to deal with
these issues it's the analogy i often
draw is about buying uh insurance for
your home burning down it's not a
probable event but you spend a very
small share of your annual income taking
out home insurance because it would be
catastrophic for your household if it
happened
but you also raised that that's very
helpful actually i think it's very good
way of putting it's not enough to have a
big scary movie that has to be like
right place right time etc um but
this
idea that
an issue like this which you would think
would be the
paradigmatic example of bipartisan
opposition like you should be
bipartisanly opposed to the end of
humanity i think uh but in fact
in various examples um
the
the idea of taking action on these has
been leveraged for partisan
purposes one way or the other i mean i
worry so since you're a working
politician tell me if i'm too worried
about this but i worry that politicians
have become too good
at using at turning any
issue into a partisan issue and the fact
that one side will be for doing
something automatically makes it suspect
to another side and you can
get people excited about that
yeah i often think about that uh ronald
reagan line that he once uttered uh in
his dotage of saying if only we had uh
aliens coming to earth we could get the
russians the americans to unite around a
common enemy uh and maybe that's why
things worked in the case of asteroid
strikes because it was the closest to
what reagan envisaged
but when it comes to nuclear disarmament
we're a long way away from that
and it is a strong partisan divide
between hawks and doves
less of a recognition that reducing the
nuclear arsenal
would just reduce the the chance of a
mistake beyond anything else
as well as measures like taking missiles
off here trigger alert and allowing call
back systems within within missiles now
all of these tend to be opposed uh by by
some of the hawks in the military
establishment even although you've had
repub republicans
like henry kissinger from time to time
coming out
and saying look reducing the size of the
nuclear stockpile would make america
safer
all right i'm getting
i don't know what to think about these
things i do have these pessimistic
moments when we start talking about
these things but but let me let me back
up and and be more philosophical about
it for a second i mean you mentioned
this number one sixth that toby ord uh
the philosopher i think um
you uh calculates as an estimate so
first question is you know where does
that come from how in the world do we
come up with a number like 1 6 one
chance in six within a century
yeah so one in six is uh toby's estimate
of putting together the total natural
risks
asteroids super volcanoes stellar
explosions
and then the
anthropogenic risks which which are much
bigger nuclear war climate catastrophe
pandemics which which occur so-called
naturally pandemics that are engineered
uh unaligned or
artificial intelligence and and i would
add to toby's list uh widespread
authoritarianism enabled by uh
surveillance technologies uh so you put
all of those together and you get a risk
that's uh in the ballpark of of one in
six uh you know just to give you a kind
of
benchmark for what that means that's
about the chance that if you're 90 years
old uh you'll die within a year
but okay i mean i think as a good
bayesian i'm entirely on board with the
idea that we should be thinking about
these probabilities but when it comes to
something like the probability of
nuclear war i'm just at a loss of how to
actually do it i mean i think i would
have given a very different answer in
1970 1980 1990 and 2000 right i mean uh
how do we get confidence in these
numbers that we try to cook up
yeah i mean these are heavily rule of uh
uh you know
back of the envelope numbers uh what
we're doing here is is envisaging both
the probability of the event multiplied
by the chance that if it happened it
would cause catastrophe so
you know the the research around nuclear
winters is is important because you want
to envisage not only what's the
probability that nuclear weapons are
launched but if they in the event that
happens uh how does that then affects
the uh the the planet the the planet
overall uh we don't have good a good
sense of either of those but they're the
two two things where we're multiplying
together yeah
okay but i mean i guess uh in the case
of nuclear war in particular can you do
you have any more details of where that
number comes from it must be someone's
estimate of the chances that some
politician is going to do something
terrible
yeah the chance a politician will do
something terrible or the chance that
there's just a mistake being being made
in the system um so you know given that
you've got uh
tens of thousands of nuclear weapons on
hair trigger alert uh you want to
envisage uh problems like the one that
we had in the cuban missile crisis where
you had a ah
soviet submarine
had depth charges being dropped near it
thinking that it was under attack almost
firing its nuclear nuclear missiles by
mistake uh so these are the
the the chance of a sort of uh an
accidental misfire then leading into a
cascade uh is uh is is
what you what you'd envisage but yeah
their best judgments by experts uh
they've got huge margins of error around
them what we're trying to do really is
get a sense of you know rough orders of
magnitude rather than really nail nail
down the last decimal point of the
probability
the point is it's bigger than you'd
think yeah okay good no i like that
answer very much it's it's of the order
ten to the minus one not ten to the
minus five and that's the important
distinction right
precisely
and so um
this but there is some again
philosophical questions here i mean
we're if we're
giving
utility uh some we're being
consequentialists in some way we're
we're
weighing the value of our future lives
and this is always an interesting
philosophical question you know i know
that economists like to discount the
future a little bit because
in part we're not there yet in part
because we don't know so is there some
discounting that goes in like if you
were really doing a cost-benefit
analysis about you know how much risk we
should tolerate versus future damage
so i love that you've gone to the
utilitarianism point because i think it
is super important uh if we massively if
we discount the future at the the
regular sort of discount rate that you
you use say five percent a year
then you get the results that uh future
people aren't worth very much uh indeed
if you discount at a rate of five
percent then you get the result that
christopher columbus is worth more than
all the eight billion people currently
alive today uh or similarly that your
life is more valuable than eight billion
lives in 500 years time and now if you
think that's absurd then you should
probably you should you're having a
problem with the notion of discounting
human life and and i do too uh i don't
think future lives have any less value
than current lives
and therefore that we should put massive
weight uh on the not not millions not
billions but trillions of lives that
will uh occupy this planet in the
billion years before the the sun engulfs
us
and the potential that if we get things
wrong those people never exist
i mean i i want to be on your side about
this and i am i think i am on your side
about this but i'm never less going to
push back because i don't think i could
defend
this with any rigor myself because
there's just so much we don't know i
mean
sure uh billions of people in the future
are are valuable and we don't want to
harm them unnecessarily or even expose
them to risk if we can avoid it on the
other hand
like how do we know that what we do
now can't be fixed with something we do
pretty easily 10 years from now and the
billions of people in the future are
fine so even though we care about them
knowing what to do for their benefit
seems very hard yeah i mean there's
certainly there's there's uncertainty
and there's the possibility we come up
with another solution but in my view
that's different from discounting sean
it's not that those people are less
valuable but you might say they have
equal value uh yet i'm choosing to take
a different set of actions in
anticipation of of change technologies
that might emerge
that's that's a reasonable approach in
my view uh but you know i share the view
of philosopher will mccaskill who says
that uh there is
the idea of saying that we're more
valuable than future generations uh is
is almost a form of prejudice that seems
to be on par with uh with racism and
sexism uh he calls it presentism uh the
idea that that we're putting our
inherent moral value uh above those of
people who who live in the future uh it
is it it's presentism to say uh that
christopher columbus is worth more than
people today it's present isn't to say
that we're worth more than people in
hundreds of years time uh we should
value their their existences which let's
hope will be far more pleasurable than
ours uh they should be able to live
lives of greater meaning and enjoyment
uh duration and health than than people
alive today
and so we we ought to be protecting them
i certainly do want to protect them but
i also would like to develop a
non-utilitarian justification for doing
so that it's exactly in these cases
where you're multiplying a tiny number
uh a tiny amount of risk by billions of
people being affected that i think that
utilitarianism is on shakiest ground
are there other justifications for
taking dramatic action right now just
you know more i don't know deontological
or virtue ethicist sort of reasons like
it's just the right thing to do
yeah i mean you can you can think about
these as your descendants if you like if
you have kids an argument which probably
is uh less
less immediately tractable to people
without kids but you know if you love
your kids you love your grandkids
there's no reason you shouldn't love
your great-great-grandkids who you'll
probably never meet or your
great-great-great-great-great-grandkids
who you'll certainly never meet
that that that sort of moral obligation
to one's genetic line argument could uh
could well be powerful with some
uh and it might just be the case that uh
that you you uh want to envisage what it
would be like at that moment at which
the uh the world is snuffed out uh and
uh you know going back to that netflix
flick uh don't look up uh that that
moment of of uh annihilation is one that
uh that ought to uh be on your minds
when you're thinking would we spend a
very small share of of the world's
resources uh in significantly reducing
uh the chance of catastrophe
why not
yeah no i think that uh
i liked don't look up but i presume that
you actually saw the movie right
yes and it's gotten a lot of controversy
because film people don't like it like
as a movie
uh there's complaints about
characterization and plot and whatever
but of course as a scientist or
politician you're like no this this is
kind of touching a nerve in a very
important way but one of the parts i
didn't find realistic is the choice of
disaster you know an asteroid which is
coming to destroy the earth and we know
exactly when it's going to happen i
think that for things like climate
change there's a big difference because
it's gradual right i mean it's coming
but it's sort of creeping up on us and
there's no threshold there's no date of
which oh this is when climate becomes
bad does that kind of difference in
uh jeopardy uh make it harder to make
sensible policies about it
yeah absolutely i mean don't look up is
uh it has a silliness about it which
makes it great theater but uh not not
necessarily a great depiction of reality
uh and the uncertainties in climate
modelling uh are real uh and have been
exploited by uh those who
want to continue to to make money under
the current system
so
like a likewise
artificial intelligence we've seen
attempts by those who were
working in the current system to say
well if you if you're in favor of
dealing of reducing artificial
intelligence risks you must be against
artificial intelligence uh and that's i
think a a silly position but you
certainly see it cropping up from time
to time
okay good i think i i got my
philosophical itch scratched a little
bit there i mean let's get down to more
brass tacks here um
let's just if it's okay with you walk
through some of the biggest existential
risks and because they're all different
right i mean they all demand slightly
different responses so maybe we can
start with the natural ones right you
know there's there's a set of of things
like volcanoes we're having this
discussion a couple days after a big
volcano right in the pacific ocean that
that was big enough to be very
noticeable without quite being
existentially worrisome but it reminds
us
uh volcanoes asteroids even i don't know
if there's something that qualifies as
an earthquake or a
solar flare that would be truly
disastrous so what how do we plan for
these things that are kind of random but
really catastrophic when they happen
well in the case of asteroids we've done
pretty well with the planetary defense
office in the case of uh
super volcanoes it's harder we're not we
seem to be particularly poor at
predicting geological events yeah
and super volcanoes are
pl you know
they're planet changing the last one was
uh
indonesia's uh toba super volcano 74 000
years ago
and and that is yeah an event which
could cause uh complete global crop
failures uh massive livestock livestock
deaths huge disease spread and so on
so uh i'm sorry the last one's uh the
new zealand one volcano 26 000 years ago
um so anyway tens of thousands of years
since we had a super volcano but we're
poor at predicting them uh so the odds
there are one comes along in the next
century are low but it would be great if
we could better pick them
right
but and do you care do you worry about
solar flares very much i once had a very
scary conversation with a lawyer who was
on some committee to study this and he
said yeah once every thousand years
there will be a solar flare big enough
to knock out our entire electrical grid
on earth and millions of people will die
and and we are doing nothing to
prevent something like that we can't
prevent it but for to uh harden the grid
to uh be able to sustain something like
that
yeah i mean i've i've got them in the
the the overall
category of of unknown uh and
non-anthropo
anthropogenic risks so you know there's
uh there's certainly a range of things
that could happen uh the fact that we
have been around on humanity for on on
the on the earth for a couple of hundred
thousand years without being wiped out
by one of these things suggests that the
odds in the next century are relatively
low uh but again the better we can do it
uh forecasting what's coming to us from
out of the atmosphere the better the
safer will be
well but i think i don't want to add
another worry to your list of
existential risks but i think this is
the this is the real worry with the
solar flares is that
its real
target is the electrical grid and so
we never had electrical grid before 100
years ago right so they could happen all
the time at the on the scale of
centuries and you know there could be a
one percent chance per year
which could be completely disastrous and
we just wouldn't know
yes although it's hard to see how it
wipes out humanity if that's the case um
so given given that our ancestors
managed to
get through without you know anything
that we can see in the in the fossil
record as looking catastrophic uh it
seems to form the category of of bad but
not catastrophic
i think that's fair although i
personally my lifestyle would be
impacted if i didn't have electricity
for a month or two so i don't want it to
happen but we certainly wouldn't be
having this conversation no i know we'd
have a podcast that'd be terrible but i
guess this it's a it's a paradigm both
the asteroids and the volcanoes and the
the solar flares these are all paradigms
for
this issue of
let's calculate a rate of risk per year
right rather than climate change which
we see happening it's just a matter of
how much it happens but where there's a
rate of something happening
pretty quickly you know how do you as a
policy maker decide how much money to
spend is there literally a set of
rational utilitarians somewhere that is
saying okay we need to spend this much
money per year to present to prevent
this risk happening with a certain
percentage chance
uh the economist jimmy would love it if
that was the case sean but of course as
you you well know uh this is not the way
in which the system works uh the the
risk risk mitigation is is better for
the the natural events
but we need to calibrate the
probabilities a little bit more
precisely
and try and get
better alignment of of spending to uh to
risk uh you know we've one of the values
i think of the conversation around
of the value of a statistical life which
was controversial when it was first
proposed is that it did cause safety
spending to be better targeted at those
things where the additional money saved
the most lives
and perhaps in the same way this
discussion about catastrophic risk
probabilities might help uh tilt funding
towards dealing with the the most likely
dangers
no i like that so this is sort of
effective altruism for or effective
charity for the world for the for the
humanity as a whole like just by
thinking about it and talking about it
maybe we will allocate our resources a
little bit more rationally is that the
hope
yeah that's right i mean i like you or
i'm a big fan of givewell.org and one of
the points that givewell make is that uh
the difference between effective and
ineffective charities isn't just two or
three times but potentially a hundred or
a thousand times efficacy
so
likewise when we're looking at these
catastrophic risks uh we've got
you know risks such as a a
an asteroid impact which is uh
over the next hundred years probably a
one in a million probability
then you've got uh uh an engineer the
chance that a uh bioterrorism event
knocks out the the world's population
that's a one in thirty uh so these are
very different probabilities uh and yet
we're probably not putting enough
resources
into
making laboratories safer and making
sure that terrorists don't put their
hands on material that could be used to
engineer the next pandemic
well okay good let's let's move on to
the topic then of pandemics and
bioterrorism there's both natural
pandemics and
uh
man-made pandemics i guess and
presumably a different suite of um
responses or or mitigation strategies
are necessary for those
yeah absolutely and so
tracking zoonotic diseases has received
considerably considerable attention as
uh covert swept the world uh and so we
need to uh to do better in terms of
those
in natural pandemics
as well as you know taking uh steps such
as working out how to reduce the the
risk of spread at the so-called wet
markets
but the bigger threat in my view is
terrorists getting there getting their
hands on
what the nixon administration once
called a poor man's atomic bomb
and for that you know we might think
about strengthening the biological
weapons convention
which currently has a monitoring budget
smaller than the budget of the typical
mcdonald's restaurant
and making sure that there is
better controls
over so-called gain of function research
in which researchers at respectable
institutions uh look at how they're able
to
make bad bugs worse um there's there's
an argument for doing that research but
in the the notion that we should uh just
publish it publish it and allow everyone
to have access to these sorts of
findings is in my view pretty dangerous
well what is the current status of uh
of exactly that i mean can uh biologists
just publish whatever results they get
along these lines or are there are they
somehow restricted in a sort of
classified knowledge kind of way
yeah so i mean let's take one of the one
of the recent examples there was a team
of researchers at the university of
alberta in canada who showed it was
possible to make horsebox uh a cousin of
smallpox by ordering parts of dna on the
internet and reassembling them they
showed they could do it for about a
hundred thousand dollars in about six
months
they submitted those findings to science
and the journal science said
no we don't think that
publishing this that the scientific
merit
outweighs so so-called dual use research
of concern which was the science
editor's way of saying bad people
getting the hold hold of the findings
but then they the researchers simply
sent the paper to another journal which
then published it
so that that's
an issue that the scientific community
is wrestling with at the moment and
having overall standards that cover not
only journals but researchers themselves
is is going to be pretty important uh
and you know i'd like it if there was as
much attention being put into this uh as
the considerable amount of attention
that's being put in countries like the
us and australia uh to researchers who
are collaborating with people in china
good uh but but there's there's a
hugely important fact lurking in the
background of what you just said which
is that it sounds
pretty easy to do bioterrorism right i
mean even if
not maybe not me in my garage but a
halfway decent science lab might be able
to just cook it up no matter what
restrictions i put on you if i'm trying
to be in secret like is that a worry
just sort of a random individual actor
uh
with a little bit of resource let's give
a million dollars to uh do some biology
can they really make a bug that would uh
hurt a lot of people
look potentially uh
gene uh genetic engineering is moving
very fast it's possible to
print dna and to for example upload a
sequence and have the dna of that
shipped to you
for very low costs and
desktop printers are
increasingly going to be become
available
so there has been a you know an
interesting proposal um mit's kevin
esvelt has made a proposal that any of
these
printing
dna printing outfits
should have built into the machinery
a system that checks essential segments
of risky sequences uh which then makes
it uh difficult for people to uh
print bugs such as the 9 10 18 influenza
strain
yeah so now my imagination is running
wild here so i i don't know why this i
hadn't thought about this before but you
know we're in the middle of pandemic now
right with kovid and in many ways it's
like a warning pandemic even though it's
been extremely terrible and deadly it
could have been enormously worse you
know it has a relatively long incubation
period but it's not that fatal and if
you wanted to design a bug that would a
bug in the in the uh casual sense of
virus that would be very very deadly you
know could you design it to
lurk inside people without any effects
for months and then turn on and become
extremely fatal that that's the worry
and
once you're at the level of designing
dna then why not yeah that's the risk so
you've got this uh spectrum the
researchers talk about a deadliness and
contagiousness and typically uh viruses
tend to be one or the other uh you know
very very deadly um so you think about
untreated hiv
extremely contagious you think about
measles or malaria
but there's relatively
few diseases thankfully which are both
extremely contagious and extremely
deadly
so the risk that you have a pathogen
that ticks both those boxes is is what
people are worried about uh with
natural pandemics but all the more so uh
with uh with
bioengineered pandemics
yeah i mean a naturally occurring
pandemic the virus has its vested
interests are not to instantly kill
everyone it infects right because it
wants to be passed on exactly but
there's no such uh
no such restraint constraint on
artificial ones this is what i i've just
now realized in talking to you that uh
you can design you could imagine
designing a virus that is way more
deadly than anything that we would
imagine naturally occurring
yes yes and uh the uh rapid advances in
uh in general technology uh you know
they have huge potential in terms of
disease alleviation and uh saving lives
around the planet we just need to make
sure sean that as we uh put those
innovations in place
we're not inadvertently assisting
those who would look to
make the pandemic equivalent of a dirty
bomb
i guess the
tiny mitigating factor is that you can't
point this bio equivalent of a dirty
bomb very precisely right like everyone
you know you would be
in danger yourself of uh
uh being adversely effective if you just
set lose a terrible new disease on the
world
yes that's right and uh you know pastor
past attempts uh haven't uh proven
successful so you know you think about
the uh arm shrinko sect uh spreading
anthrax
in tokyo subways they did initially try
and find uh some uh uh
disease that they could uh they could
unleash uh but they they weren't i
weren't able to do it um so they used
sorry they used sarin gas in the in the
end
and
and that was that was because their
attempts to uh by engineer a disease uh
hadn't worked out um similarly there was
a set of a set of poisonings in oregon
that took place in 1984 yeah there it's
actually the worst biological terror
attack in in american history
which involved the poisoning of salad
bars
that group had previously looked at
spreading hiv aids but hadn't worked out
how to weaponize it
so these these terrorist groups have
tried and failed in the past
the challenge is to ensure that they
keep on failing in the future
maybe this gets into things that you're
not allowed to talk about but um i
always presume that if there's some
technology
that could be used for better or for ill
um it will be developed and it will be
used by somebody so i presume that
governments in secret are developing bio
weapons even if they plan to never use
that is government uh
uh
development of these kinds of things
just as big a worry as terrorist group
development look i i don't think so in
in advanced countries at least uh and
the the decision that the the nixon
administration made in putting in place
the biological weapons convention was
that these are fundamentally weapons
that are more useful to less powerful
states
and that it's strongly in america's
interest to not be involved in in
working on
bugs as a form of weaponry
so the u.s
had a range of programs which it then
shut down under the next administration
following the biological weapons
convention uh we've had some evidence
that the the the shutdown by the soviets
wasn't as complete
and
certainly there's there's been other
incidents such as
saddam hussein's use of
chemical weapons on his own people
but largely i i i think it is the case
that uh in advanced countries there's
not uh secret research going on into
biological weapons because of the
recognition that uh that these are
as nixon said a poor man's atomic bomb
yeah okay that does make some sense i'm
not quite sure because i never know what
countries are doing in secret but i
think that you know your the uh
motivations that you mentioned do make a
lot of sense for the terrorist groups or
just for the mad scientist or whatever
um the fact that we can buy our own
genetic uh
kits dna
uh writers and so forth uh you mentioned
that it would be sensible to at least
imagine
restrictions on either the technology or
the publication of the technology
how specific are proposals along those
lines to you know not let people just
buy a dna engineering kit or or not
publish the results if they figure out
how to re-engineer smallpox
yeah i think uh you know kevin asfelt's
uh proposal is pretty specific and makes
it makes a lot of sense uh and that
ought to apply not only to firms that
are shipping dna but also to uh bench
top dna synthesis machines uh that's
that then becomes yeah
ensuring that people can't kind of can't
do it at home uh the concern around
research publication i think has
crystallized into a number of quite
sensible proposals uh you know runs
counter to the ethos that you and i are
so familiar with in universities that uh
that publish your parish idea that when
you've got uh new findings you you share
them with the world right and so i can
understand the discomfort that people
have uh about uh uh keeping keeping
research silent uh but in this case uh i
think it's it's strongly in the interest
of humanity
okay but are there like uh bills in
front of parliament or so forth or or
how advanced is this effort to uh think
this through
no it's still in the in the in the realm
of uh sort of concrete policy proposals
uh but i certainly hope that it'll uh
it'll come into it'll crystallize into
clear codes of practice and uh and
legislation in the coming years
okay and then you know to just to wrap
up the pandemics uh there's still the
naturally occurring pandemics that we
have to worry about you know i'm a
little depressed as i think a lot of
people are at how badly we as a species
have responded to this particular
pandemic do you think that
will be better next time are there
obvious right things to do or do you
think that for going forward pandemics
are going to be political footballs as
we say here in the united states
yeah i certainly hope that we're going
to get uh better in terms of uh making
sure that pandemics don't leak out of
labs uh you know there's a there's a
theory this one leaked it leaked out of
a lab i think that's probably wrong but
it's certainly the case that the last
person to die of smallpox uh caught it
from a lab leak rather than from
naturally occurring smallpox
so we we do need to be careful around
lab leaks and making sure that bsl4
facilities uh have better
better safeguards around them would make
a lot of sense we could also do more in
terms of having detection facilities
one of the ways in which we picked up on
covert early was this program for
monitoring emerging diseases so-called
pro-med
in which doctors were just posting
findings that they found and pro-med was
collating them together
their pro-med's global budget is one
million dollars a year which is about
what it costs to build a suburban
playground
the idea that that's the the best we can
do as a planet seemed nuts to me uh i'd
be increasing pro-med's budget
substantially because i think they're
one of our best uh early detection
weapons against pandemics uh whether
they're natural or
and what about things like um
we did pretty good job of developing a
vaccine we did a much less good job of
making it widely available especially
worldwide and we did a terrible job at
convincing people to take it i i would i
would argue uh do you see paths forward
to doing better next time
yeah i mean as a politician i've been
thinking a lot about how you get ahead
of disinformation and certainly a lot of
the stuff i've read suggests that
in some ways you want to inoculate
people against the hoaxes before they
come that once a hoax has taken root in
people's mind
it's quite hard to dislodge it so among
indigenous australian communities for
example
the hoaxes got there in many cases
before the government
with the idea that
the vaccine was being given to those
communities first
because it was being tested on them
and and once that idea had taken root in
communities it's become quite hard to
vaccinate indigenous communities so as a
the overall australian vaccination rate
is good the rate in indigenous
communities is bad and that's just a
microcosm with of the overall challenge
of dealing with disinformation uh we've
got to get out there before the bad
actors do and warn people of the the
character of the disinformation messages
that are to come uh look out for these
these stories uh this is what people
will tell you and this is why you
shouldn't and is that something we i
mean i um this is an obvious answer to
this question presumably we should be
doing that before the pandemic heads
right i mean there should be an ongoing
kind of program i don't even know what
it would look like though i mean to tell
people who are naturally skeptical
someday there's going to be a pandemic
and we're going to want to vaccinate you
please don't reject it
yeah right i mean part of it is
scientific literacy uh part of it also
is uh making sure that uh that we're
rigorously testing the uh
anti-disinformation messages um so
there's a couple of good papers i've
been reading recently uh randomized
trials just testing different strategies
because it is one of those areas shown
where your gut doesn't tell you very
much uh where in fact we now know that
uh
repeating repeating the hoax the hoax
can cause it to sink deeper into
people's minds and that sometimes it's
better not to mention the lie at all
yeah so this is research in
psychology what would you even call it
what is the research we have to do to
understand this better
yeah right it's sort of a blender the
researchers that i've seen are
accommodation of public health and
social psychology um and you know they
come up with uh with useful useful
findings the notion of the fact sandwich
comes out of that so if you have to
mention the lie then start with the
truth mention the lie
mention the truth again and so at least
you're giving a double dose of truth for
every time you mention mention the lie
that fact sandwich idea has come out of
clever randomized trials on messaging um
it's one part of dealing with
disinformation but it's going to be
increasingly important if populism
continues to maintain the hold it's got
in many advanced countries
well yeah i mean i think we will get
there but maybe it's okay to take things
out of order you know it's not just
disinformation right there's a
motivation a political motivation on
some sides
to
take the let's say the anti-vaccination
uh stance or or something equivalent and
that seems like a tougher nut to crack
in terms of prevention
yeah that's right if you want to build a
powerful
support base then finding an issue such
as
a conspiracy theory can be really useful
uh you go back to to the way in which uh
the nazis used conspiracy theories about
uh jewish people to uh to fuel their
eyes conspiracy theories about uh
african americans have been used through
by various uh american populists uh you
see in in
india the use of of conspiracy theories
about uh muslims to uh to fuel the sort
of hindutva movement which has taken
over the bj ruling bjp
um that's sort of
weaponizing of conspiracy theories uh to
target a uh small
to spread fear about a small group in
the population is a tried and true
tactic for populists around the world
yes and how do we stop that
to ask you a completely unfair question
yeah i mean i think we first of all need
to uh to call it out and calling out
racism turns out to be a pretty
effective way of combating the political
weaponization of racism
recognising that the rise of populism
does in part have its roots in economic
problems
the the loss of good middle class jobs
the hollowing out of manufacturing has
been a source uh that uh the the
populist anger has tapped into
and recognizing too that you you can't
fight fire with fire uh and that if
you're looking at an alternative uh
political approach then that needs to be
the kind of calm stoic approach uh which
characterizes
leaders
you know such such as nelson mandela uh
rather than a sort of angry approach
which uh which doesn't seem to be
effective against populism
well this is i think and this is a big
picture
message of your book i think correct me
if i'm wrong or or tweak it as you will
but
the real lesson of thinking carefully
about these existential risks is not
just oh against risk number one we do
this against risk number two we do that
but rather we really kind of have to
think hard about our whole approach to
politics and even life uh to really
adapt to the fact that we face
existential risks now in a way that
maybe we didn't
previously in human history
yeah that's right and strengthening
democracy is an important way of
reducing the hold that populism has
gained on our politics
when i look at the u.s constitution
i i regret that jefferson's ambition of
an update every generation has
essentially been been dropped for the
last two generations
which means that you have a democracy
that's not as democratic as it should be
um so i've talked about a number of uh
democratic reforms that i think would
would make sense in the united states
context you know holding elections on
weekends or holidays uh reforming the
the electoral college uh encouraging uh
active citizenship uh the kind of uh
detailed community engagement rather
than simply engaging on social media as
a as a substitute for real political
action um but we also need to realize
that uh good
politics involves acting with with
calmness and wisdom
rather than rather than trying to to
beat
populists at their own game
now that's a great message but it does
what you just said um
shifts my attention a little bit because
you know a lot more about american
politics than i do about australian
politics
before i forget can you just like say a
little bit about what it's like to kind
of be in this
anglo-american english-speaking
tradition but be in a different country
in in australia like you have to like
kind of keep up with political and
social movements in both where you are
and in the us just because the us is is
so influential
oh look i'm uh married to an american i
spent four years of my life in the in
the u.s
you know i'm i'm as interested in in
american politics as the politic
politics of any other country except my
own so it's a
a pleasure rather than a duty to to
follow american politics but
i i do see so much in the american
democratic experience that suggests that
the beacon of democracy that america was
two centuries ago uh is now shining less
less brightly uh and i look at uh at the
the changes
changes that uh that are be involved as
is essentially uh part of that
responsibility that democracies have to
keep on improving their systems uh not
to sit back and say uh this is ideal
we'll never never do it and doing it do
anything more
i suppose the most radical proposal i
would would have is to treat voting as a
civic duty
just as uh
americans are required to
fill in the census just as americans are
required to serve on duties on juries
i think having compulsory voting would
significantly improve turnout and make
turnout more representative of the
population as a whole and am i right
that you have that in australia or
something like it
yeah we do and uh you know we haven't we
don't have 100 turnout but we have uh
much higher turnout than most advanced
countries do uh largely because not not
because people are fearful of being
fined but simply because the the fine
which is you know less than one hour's
average wage
is is something which spurs a civic duty
and makes people feel it's election day
i will go and vote rather than you know
will i will i or won't i go to the polls
today
but this goes back to this idea that we
that we talked about very briefly before
that politicians have become very good
at weaponizing potentially controversial
issues so even if one political party in
the u.s got behind that there's no
chance the other one would
so i i'm very skeptical that things like
that are going to actually happen
right right and so this requires uh
leaders who are willing to make uh
decisions which are in the interests of
the polity as a whole rather than simply
in the interest of their their narrow
political party uh you know we've got
past examples of that uh leader
leaderships of both parties that have
chosen to make decisions in the national
interest
but like you i worry that we're seeing
less and less of it
and
the increasingly tight hold that donald
trump now exerts over the the republican
party uh is a is a real concern uh and
the as is the fact that you know almost
three quarters of republican voters
believe that donald trump won the 2020
election
i think while you're in that environment
it's quite hard to
to get the requisite changes that ensure
that uh
america's democratic ideals are realized
well i agree and i also
perceive that
the diminution of a devotion to
democracy
does occur on both sides of the
political spectrum even if it's one
side's fault i'm not trying to sort of
both sides say every everyone is you
know at fault etc um
both sides here in the united states
have lost
any motivation for working along with
the other side and i don't care whose
fault it is that's a bad situation for a
democracy to be in
yeah yeah i agree and uh you know one of
the most influential books to me in
recent years has been etan hirsch's book
politics is for power which makes the
case that increasingly americans are
treating politics more like they treat
their
local sporting teams
cheer and jeer from the sidelines but
don't think that you can actually affect
the game
rather than actually rather than
going out on the field and trying to
make a difference and
etan talks about the importance of
getting involved in your local community
uh and and trying to uh to think of
yourself very much as a player in the
political spectrum uh and that also
means that at a local level because
party labels are much less salient
you're much more likely to be to be
working with people rather than just uh
shouting at them
interesting i'll have to check that out
that's a good recommendation but but
okay i mean this is this is probably the
most important thing we're talking about
but i don't want to forget that we're
going down a list of possible
existential risks because they're all
different i mean we've mentioned climate
change a lot
um but what is your take on the current
amount of progress we're making i mean
we keep trying to have international
agreements and it's hard to make them
happen and then people violate them
it seems to be kind of a recipe for
cynicism a little bit
yeah i'm certainly concerned that uh
what came out of glasgow is inadequate
for what the the planet needs uh you
know you look at climate action tracker
which looks at the number of nations
that have implemented climate policies
consistent with a two degree of warming
target
it finds only a handful have done so
even the european union it says are only
only coming close uh many countries are
insufficient or critically insufficient
including yours and mine
so yeah we do need to do an awful lot
more and what's striking about it is
that a lot of it involves installing
energy sources which is zero marginal
cost uh so ultimately a lot of this will
uh will pay for itself in cheaper energy
yeah it seems like there is good news on
the technology front right i mean solar
and other renewables have gotten cheaper
a lot faster than people thought they
would
absolutely and and the guy so the gains
from installing there are
substantial uh and what's important too
is then to think about this not just at
a national level but also at a community
level
so if you've got a coal-fired power
station which is slated for closure then
you can take advantage of the
electricity connections coming into that
plant in order to use that as a site for
a wind farm or a solar farm and create
the have the construction jobs that go
along with that at the same time as well
as the some maintenance jobs in the
future no i like that that's a very
clever idea and then of course we have
the final risk i want to dwell on is the
ai risk you've mentioned that already
this is the one that you said you hadn't
really been conscious of when you came
into your job but you've uh read up on
it and now you're kind of worried
yeah absolutely and you know again we've
got two two questions uh will it happen
and how bad will it be if it happens uh
the there's differences among uh
artificial intelligence researchers at
the point of time at which artificial
intelligence will exceed
human ability
the median guess in one recent survey
was 2061
but almost no one working in the area
says it's impossible computers will
never outperform humans in
in the sorts of tasks we envisage
whether that's you know writing a
best-selling book or driving a truck or
solving mathematical problems
so then once computers go past us what
happens well presumably they accelerate
past us at a pretty rapid rate
so you know you look at the uh
performance of of chess computers
if you put a chess computer up against a
human the chess computer now wins 99 of
the time uh and in go uh the probability
the machine wins is
99.99995 percent um so you know this is
this is essentially saying that now
computers playing these games uh are as
likely to beat us
as
the world heavyweight boxing champion
would be to beat me in a boxing match
so so once they accelerate past us
what do we know about their values
well it's
we hope that they share our values but i
don't think that's locked in by any
means uh and the possibility that uh uh
or
that uh super intelligent machines have
a set of values that are either
antithetical to human existence or more
likely just orthogonal to it
is a real one uh and and we need to be
very careful how we develop these
computers uh that they don't somehow
damage out our prospects as a species
quite substantially
i mean i guess i have some skepticism
about the um rate of progress of ai in
truly human
general intelligence kind of tasks i
think it's very different than go or
chess but for the worries that you have
it doesn't have to be right it doesn't
have to be human-like intelligence as
long as we are seeding power uh in some
way to these algorithms we we could get
in trouble but so my trip my question is
what exactly would be the scenario that
we're worried about i mean so imagine
that ai becomes very very smart uh what
is it going to do that will harm us how
specific could we be about that
uh the short answer is we don't know but
uh you know you can take the next nick
bostrom example of a supercomputer which
decides that it wants to build as many
paperclips as possible uh it doesn't
want to hurt us but our buildings and
our cars turn out to be good raw
materials for paper clip building and so
it massively destroys humanity's
prospects and the result or you can
imagine that we try and encode our
values but we do so the wrong way
so we say to the the computer we want
you to uh maximize human happiness and
it puts our brains in vats uh uh feeding
feeding us drugs to uh to maximize our
pleasure centers uh we say that we want
it to
uh if you
find a cure for cancer so it increases
the rate of cancer detection it
increases the underlying rate of cancer
uh so that it can improve detection uh
these sorts of problems you know called
perverse instantiation or a king midas
problem
do
do trouble artificial intelligence
researchers
and suggest that we want to in think
about
encoding computers
which have three qualities that they're
observant humble and altruistic
so we're not locking in a particular
moral code but we're asking these
supercomputers to watch us
to
act in our interests
and to recognize that there might be a
lot of complexities about human society
and they want to be learning from that
in order to to help us
that's that all sounds great in
principle uh the trouble is if you've
got an ai race uh particularly uh one
that's uh being conducted
through the lens of global competition
between superpowers then you might end
up with the first super intelligence not
sharing uh our values
i i guess
yeah i have a lot of questions about
this and i know this is not exactly uh
your expertise but you know i so let me
let me say the dumbest most naive
question i have uh probably the answers
to this one are pretty easy but
if if i have a
ai algorithm running on my computer that
just goes bad breaks bad and starts
doing bad things i can unplug my
computer
and so i think the scenarios that we're
envisioning here are imagining not just
an ai gone bad but some kind of embodied
a.i that is almost human-like in its
capacities and so forth and what i worry
is that we're being too anthropocentric
we're we're putting we're imagining ais
that are kind of human-like but the real
danger will come from ais that have very
different capacities that we haven't
really thought about enough
yeah so the reason we can't just switch
it off at the wall i think is because if
it's smarter than us
then it'll want to self-improve to
acquire resources and resist being shut
down which means it'll do everything it
can
to try and avert a situation in which
you just turn it off
and there's a lovely
analogy for this sean there's an
artificial intelligence agent which was
designed to maximize its score in tetris
uh that game with a with a bricks drop
down
now as you know tetris can't be won
because ultimately the last brick comes
into place and so this game had a
strategy which involved getting to the
last moment and then pausing the game
and many people have noticed that that
the behavior of that artificial
intelligence agent is not that different
from what you would envisage from a
super intelligence which was resisting
being turned off
so we've seen it already in the lab and
to some extent uh and and defying
shutdowns is is going to be one of the
things that a super intelligence puts a
lot of resources into into achieving
okay no i like that example very very
much but i i do think that it actually
highlights one of the distinctions here
because i can imagine an ai that is way
more intelligent than i have that i am
but almost everything much better at not
only chess and go but symphonies and
fiction writing
but has no
self-preservation instincts at all right
uh i mean it seems like the the angle
here is that we should worry about
giving ai self-preservation instincts
yeah i'm i'm not sure that uh
i can envisage an ai which uh has
any
substantial desire but doesn't care
about being being turned off i would
have thought pretty much any desire you
begin with uh or to or to then
effectively encode a uh a design not to
be turned off um you know ultimately
this uh this comes down to asthma
whether asmod's third law is is
necessary or unnecessary you know his is
his threat
his laws uh don't injure humans obey
orders and protect yourself um some
people say protect yourself doesn't need
to be in there because uh the the the
other the other the other two
effectively encoded right
yeah but yeah okay i mean um i i do well
again this is just vague worries i
haven't thought about this in a
systematic way but uh i worry that all
of our experience is from biological
organisms that grew up through evolution
rather than being designed so
for us
intelligence and self-preservation
instincts just go hand in hand it's very
natural but they but they needn't uh in
in the ai context that's my vague worry
but i don't want to dwell on it um what
i do want to dwell on just just to you
know wrap things up with some final
thoughts um
more thoughts on the global strategy or
the human scale strategy here i mean one
thing that i was interested that you
pooh-poohed as a strategy is the elon
musk idea of backing up the biosphere of
you know if we spread human beings out
to other planets we're less likely to to
blow up ours and therefore end humanity
and you you didn't seem that much in
favor of that one or at least you
weren't that impressed with that
suggestion
right i mean
largely it's because i'm a cost-benefit
guy and when i look at the cost of that
strategy it seems to be massive relative
to the costs of strategies such as
better coordinating ai races uh between
existing teams um there's also the the
massive loss that would come from the
destruction of uh planet earth and all
that we've built here um so you know i
think we could do better
in
getting clear global guidelines on
ethical ai
interestingly there was a proposal in
2018 from justin trudeau and emmanuel
macron for an international panel on
artificial intelligence and they had the
international panel on climate change as
a model
but the trump administration didn't
support it in part because they thought
it would
impede the development of artificial
intelligence
to which i'd respond well it's only
impeding the development of bad
artificial intelligence uh let's get the
guard rails in place before we build the
highway uh if you uh if you build the
super intelligence first and then try
and think about its ethical rules uh
things could you could find that you've
left it too late
okay that does make sense i like the
cost-benefit uh angle there but speaking
of which um the final thing is is this
uh
kind of vague utopian but but
nevertheless attractive idea you have of
um
thinking differently about these kinds
of questions i mean you you you talk the
your book ends talking about wisdom and
stoicism which is not how most
politicians book ends actually and maybe
they maybe they do i don't really know i
don't read many books by politicians
these days but but how do we make people
wiser and uh more stoic that sounds like
a big global project that i wouldn't
even know how to start doing that
yeah i'm not sure that i have a good
strategy for uh populising stoicism i
suspect ryan holiday is probably better
on that than me but
it is
the philosophical approach that in my
view is there is the right strategy to
respond to populism
that idea that we need the values of
courage prudence justice and moderation
that we should be rewarding people who
are uh being bold in service of truth uh
that we should be uh celebrating a love
of wisdom uh that we should be
encouraging a fairness in in the
treatment of people
and also that
living a calm and a disciplined life
rather than a a shouty or a chaotic
existence uh is to be celebrated
uh and you know it's not as though we
haven't seen examples of this rising to
the top uh you you look at uh uh uh
marcus aurelius
and
the the life of epictetus uh not to
mention the the the success of those
such as nelson mandela in uh
his not only in robben island but in
leading his own country uh gandhi is as
well uh this it's a tradition with uh
a quite a a rich lineage and one that i
believe
is is the right strategy uh in an age in
which we we want to ensure that the
population uh not only survives but that
a whole ah
millions of future generations come
after us
okay so but how do we do it i mean i
mean i'm totally in favor of of this
what i worry is that you list some
virtues and everyone goes yes those are
great virtues but then you
operationalize them and people go oh no
i don't mean that i didn't mean that we
were going to let immigrants in or
whatever it is right i mean
how how do you make that connection
between values that we're all willing to
get behind and acting them out in the
way that
we're hoping people do
well for me as a politician it's about
uh resisting the urge to uh to to go for
the jugular and to to
make personal attacks that aren't
necessary as well as recognizing that
when the temperature is turned up it's
generally not going to advantage those
who care about the long term
so all of these things can be pretty
pretty tempting and there's certainly
plenty of those who say that left-wing
populism is the answer to right-wing
populism uh so you know that's there's a
sense in which this is a kind of
personal uh person personal project for
any uh politician who wants to make a
difference to reducing catastrophic risk
whether they're on the left or the right
and you can identify plenty of those
who've
adhered to stoic values on the on the
right over the years
but it's also something where uh you
would you'd envisage uh celebrating a
different kind of uh of media engagement
for example uh the the shouting heads
media engagement uh should be looked on
more as a
as a spectacle of amusement rather than
being a serious way of engaging in
politics
yeah i mean maybe at the end of the day
the best thing we can do is be exemplars
of these virtues that we want other
people to have i guess
precisely
all right that's something to aim for i
like it i like uh leaving the podcast
with a goal or something for people to
uh think about and try to get better at
so andrew lee thanks so much for being
on the mindscape podcast
it's been a treat sean thank you
[Music]
you